nous allons vous entraîner dans un
univers ou en couleur et très
particulier celui des drag queens on les
voit partout elles font la une des
magazines le succès des boîtes à la mode
elles se veulent une réponse extrême à
la grisaille de notre société à coude de
corsages flamboyant et de maquillage
outrancier mais au delà de la fête et de
l'ambigüité y at-il quelque chose
derrière le masque sont elles un
phénomène de mode au contraire
l'expression d'un dérèglement de notre
société pour y répondre
michel mompontet et philippe chasselas
ont suivi lola et leanne et herat dans
le monde fantasque des belles de nuit
[Musique]
se construire un visage se faire un
masque de fait ne change rien à la
sphère de jour comme de nuit elle et
lola 23 en drag queen très longtemps
même avant soit draquila
15 ans bon c'était un concours de
circonstances en fait c'était à l'époque
où j'étais encore à l'école
je faisais pendant les interclasses rire
les copains évidemment et je faisais
marilyn monroe comme ça pied levé
et juste aux gens sont arrivés à manama
l'un l'état up nous ratons surtout face
aux recteurs que tu as vu pour x ray en
classe et voilà du coup mention domaine
lolita
et puis en vieillissant j'ai juste
trouvé que le la 7eme fois ça me
paraissait très longtemps lolita c'est
vite devenu le linge
il faudra à eliane et lola trois heures
de préparation et la complicité de tous
leurs amis stylistes coiffeurs avant de
ressembler enfin à ceux qui habitent
leur imaginaire
à cette poupée kitsch qui hante leurs
fantasmes trois heures pour passer d'un
sexe bien l'eau
est ce que tu peux qu'est ce que c'est
les différences entre investi entre cool
non ce n'est pas
que
la clé travesti envie que les drag queen
pas forcément enfin si on peut faire une
différence
c'est la même démarche de l'année où est
passé mon
attention ne dit jamais à une drag-queen
qu elle se déguise une drag queen ce
look
le glas quand vous vous look et vous
savez ce que vous inspirez de quelqu'un
déjà existant est ce que vous créez
puisque je pars pas par rapport de
quelqu'un qui existe déjà mais c'est
comme ça une synthèse de plusieurs
personnages mais c'est un petit peu
toujours les mêmes démons quoi c'est
qu'ils sont ses dépens marlène naufrage
en a placé ses allées good ça dépend des
fois ça a évolué d'être un personnage
non moins mythique peut-être
de chez tati et célèbres
sait on jamais
c'est un jour de fête une fête au grand
jour eliane pink harrington labrune et
lola la blonde avait pour une fois
revêtu leurs plus beaux atours mais en
plein jour oui alors
qu'est ce que tu veux encore non tu
n'auras pas d'argent c'est fini terminé
je ne sais pas une banque oui alors
mario comment vagues à bonds ces lignes
on te dit que tu voudras mais non c'est
non c'est fini c'est terminé je suis le
robinet est permis
[Musique]
cet après-midi-là sur les boulevards
parisiens les attendait la gay pride la
marche annuelle pour la reconnaissance
des droits des homosexuels
mais c'est seulement en arrivant dans le
cortège que nous avons finalement
compris kélian et lola avait somme toute
plutôt choisi la sobriété vestimentaire
ayrault
une diva c'est une diva du sénat
m
à
se montrer s'exhiber à tout prix comme
autant de revendications de leur
identité
entre le carnaval de rio et la festival
de cannes toute une après midi durant
une vision idyllique de l'identité
homosexuelle de l'identité drag queen
[Musique]
elles étaient toutes belles nous étions
tous tolérant une après-midi d'aurel
mais une fois cette grande marche
terminé
le soir même il y avait une sono à deux
doigts d'être inaudible eliane sur le
podium d'un restaurant gay à moitié vide
pour 700 francs trois défilés chansons
mais le tout pourtant avec conviction
malgré le vide la déprime qu'inspiré ce
spectacle
[Musique]
davines et fait des choses grosse perf'
ciel qui ont d'aspe absolument
complètement et surtout totalement
superficiel on a l'impression d'être que
je n'ai pas compris mais on a
l'impression en écoutant que tous les
tous les grands problèmes que traverse
la sottise la société aujourd'hui et
même l'oeuvre pour être plus générale
savoir le chômage la misère et la mort
la vie la vieillesse tout ça tout ça est
complètement évacué le tas d'autres
manières de vivre ses goûts mais doute
fait de façon très forte quoi oui c'est
vrai non mais je ne peux pas du tout du
genre enfin je veux dire ah bon j'ai
quitté mes parents à l'âge de 17 ans et
demi je suis arrivé à paris à l'âge de
18 ans
et je n'ai jamais jamais jamais dormi
dehors où
cette ville map adapté et c'est vrai que
bon j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait pour
travailler et c'est un dj etc mais
j'aurais très bien pu mal tourner comme
tellement d'autres gens et bon jeu
d'avoir un instinct de conservation et
de préservation très fort toujours est
il que tout ça le chômage etc tous ces
cris ça me concerne peu parce que je
m'arrange toujours par exemple ce soir
je fais un petit show comme sabre c'est
rohff c310 ou pour moi mais ça me permet
de vivre ça et je hais je dis
bien tout le monde et c'est très bien je
fais ce que je sais que je fais ce qu'il
me plaît même s'il forme ce soir c'est
vraiment infernal mais
j'estime le faire avec
un élément de conviction ces traits un
peu des gens que cette soirée lat dior
sa et
souvent beaucoup de bonheur il ya des
grands bois leur part mais ça ressemble
à quoi ces grands mots mais arrivé de
quoi ça ressemble à une décharge
d'adrénaline d'électricité qui leur dit
si jusque là on passe encore ici
tout le corps comme ça et en général ça
murray peu près le même effet pas
d'orgasme samedi en deux semaines
et je dis ça je vais sans drogue
sans fil d'un documentaire et les il ya
aussi j'imagine des grands coup de
spleen ah oui aussi des appels de
détresse
[Musique]
s'il pouvait avoir des enfants je pense
que je serai moins
bizarroïde comme on pourrait dire
perpignan que merci à perpignan pourquoi
qu'est ce que tu crois bien sûr c'est
l'internet et une maternité qui savent
vous situez si tu avais des enfants un
mois ce sont interdites et qu'est ce que
tu crois que ça ramènerait le fait de ne
pas déjà avoir quelque chose de vivant
qui n'y va pas tous et qui fabriqué avec
des choses qui viennent ici c'est un peu
banal et mon ex et de réfléchir sur
beaucoup de choses et éliminé d'office
millions d'autres je
[Musique]
parie banana café 22h30 c'est là que
s'écrit chaque soir le premier chapitre
des nuits des drag queens la fête ici ne
commence qu'à leur arrivée
l'afom moi c'est d'arriver vous
l'entendrez y aller
et
enfin les théories profite sans procéder
souhaite
faire carrière dans des tons
genève j'ai bien dû jouer des coudes et
connor
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais
l'habitat
m
quand de la nouvelle garde espoir
pour les dragons qui se cantonnaient
look et on a l'impression d'être au plus
près de nous même est ce que c'est votre
avis aussi ça dépend chacun son choix
c'est dire moi ou mon délire c'est
ce que je veux faire une bonne affaire
quand tu auras queen je vais faire
maintenant pas de faire un petit garçon
donc j'en profite d'être dans la crise
pour pouvoir délivrer un maximum comme
sa cote quand la semaine quand je
travaille pas je regarde faut je reste
stable sur jeans baskets et je passe
incognito voilà
justement là entre la vie de garçon et
la vie de drag queen est-ce que c'est
pas difficile à gérer les deux est ce
que ces deux personnages qui sont en
vous est ce que c'est le même
schéma assez des personnages de
personnages d'histoires moi-même
s'annonce complètement différent en fait
sa survie personne et c'est moi et c'est
kivu dario
voilà
et vous pourrez vous rêvez commandant
cinq ans
comment je me verrais
des plans à coup il chantera délire et
jean lagacé m'occuper justement de
soirées ou des drag queens ou
complètement changé je sais pas mais
c'est clair que je rappellerai toute ma
vie c'est un délire c'est un passage
d'une vie
dracula 30 ans non
vous avez des lads 23
dario n'était même pas encore nés que
fanni était déjà une des stars des nuits
parisiennes
fanny est une femme mais cela fait plus
de trente ans quelle honte ce quartier
comme animatrice comme fêtarde ou comme
maman il maman un peu spécial certes
fanni est la reine des drag queens
est ce que vous sentez vous en tant que
femme pour elle pour moi c'est mes
filles donc voyez les sujets mais si j'y
mets sujet ça fait prétentieux malabat
sinécure
je peux vous poser une question un peu
plus
un discret sourire est ce que vous êtes
vous avez des enfants mais non non non
c'est un peu mes enfants aussi c'est mes
filles mes enfants quelque part vous
avez une relation très maternelle a vécu
avec elle oui je les maternelles
ce soir là parmi les clients du banana
café il en étant un peu particulier et
pour cause
c'est nous qui l'avons amené la barre
gérard caron et designers sociologue il
est l'un des spécialistes du look dans
la planète publicitaire pour nous il va
étudier décortiquer ce phénomène drag
queen
on peut s'expliquer le fait qu'il aura
quoi il est choisi de vivre que la nuit
je pense qu'en fin de compte le drag
queen ça ne peut vivre que la nuit parce
que c'est un phénomène qui t'a fait
exacerbée extraordinaire
erci tous et une queen dans un cadre de
vie tout à fait ordinaire d'un seul coup
s'est montré aussi un peu le pathétique
de la situation alors qu'ici c'est un la
nuit c'est la fête c'est un monde que
l'on s'est choisi c'est un monde qui est
coupé de la réalité de même que la drac
où il marche sur des talons très hauts
qu'il a un couple de la réalité d'une
certaine façon elle ne touche pas le sol
bien c'était à fait logique que ce soit
dans un an dans un monde de ski
d'abondance curité de la fête mais
vit toujours à côté de de l'ambiguïté
sait faire la fête mais la mort la nuit
n'oublions pas quand même qu'il ya une
énorme des 13 derrière tout cela et
c'est une façon de se battre contre cela
ou peut-être de ne pas en parler de ne
pas évoquer cela la mort dans le
phénomène drag queen est tout à fait
présente à de nombreux signes parce que
c'est eux mêmes un hiver pour une grande
majorité d'homosexuels et il ya une
menace en priorité sur ce milieu qui est
le sida et les drag queen vivent avec
cela c'est une façon de faire un
pied-de-nez à la mort aussi
et pendant que dario et ses soeurs drag
queen continue de narguer la mort en
dansant autour d'elle les bonnes
affaires commencent à s'organiser le
show biz a déjà débarqué
tournage du vidéoclip comme une première
consécration pour ces trois drag queen
et sister queen prison même par une
grande maison de disques le producteur
avait déjà réussi un gros coup il ya
quelques années en produisant jordi et
son dur dur d'être un bébé philippe
renault peut avoir le sourire le coup
était bien préparé
[Musique]
on estime que des choses qui soit en
phase avec la programmation dans les
discothèques donc lorsqu'on écoute un
disque la première chose qui nous
intéresse c'est ce que le tempo convient
aux discothèques est ce que ça peut
faire remplir les pistes est ce que ça
peut séduire les dj c'est notre premier
raisonnement est en plus effectivement
on était intéressé par sister queen
parce que on avait un deuxième potentiel
qui est que c'était la première fois un
groupe de drag queen avait un disque qui
était crédible alors que d'habitude les
drag queen dans sur les disques des
autres et petits 2 c'est que le visuel
était très nettement supérieur à la
moyenne du groupe dance et qu'on savait
qu'on allait développer le produit
beaucoup plus grâce à ça
là aussi nous avons amené gérard caron
pour assister et analyser cette
récupération instantané d'un phénomène
de société et sa transformation
immédiate ont produit très lucratif
il ya le phénomène drag queen et ils
s'adressent à nous pour nous dire on
marche plus on ne joue plus votre monde
qui est un monde de confusion un monde
amalgame alors que c'est drag queen joue
de la confusion d'un amalgame mais ce
votre monde qui est gris votre monde de
frein votre monde de christ est ce autre
monde de mauvaises nouvelles votre monde
de politique de droite menée par des
gens de gauche pour du type de gauche
mené par des gens de droite à toute
sorte de confusion mode au niveau des
sexes on ne marchait plus c'est à dire
que nous imposons d'autres codes noms
propres codes nous imposons nos propres
circuits c'était c'est un univers qui
veuille montclos et la nuit c'est un
phénomène citadins
donc tout cela signifie qu'en fin de
compte c'est pas un effet de miroir
c'est un effet d'exagération mais si on
sait décoder si on ne sait dire ce que
nous essayons de faire en ce moment il
ya tout de même un message et même si ce
message porte un nom quand on regarde
l'histoire aussi c'était un nom un peu
terrible à assumer mais il faut pas
avoir peur de le dire ce mot qui est là
qui est derrière tout cela a observé
c'est comme un mot qui s'écrit décadence
et c'est notre propre décadence que les
drag queens nous envoie et nous renvoie
alors qu'allons nous en faire de nos
propres décadence c'est pas leurs
problèmes leurs problèmes à elle c'est
le jeu c'est dense et la dérision par
rapport à cela mais le problème subsiste
elles ne peuvent pas résoudre surnom
peur après un
drag queen extravaganza
baby jack wills excès du cians let me be
jack krine extra gaza let me be a drag
queen promotion
m
et pendant que le titre let me be a drag
queen laisse-moi être une drag queen
passe il repasse au banana café une des
stars des temps immémoriaux du disco se
retrouvent par les difficultés de la
circulation
piégé par tyra et notre caméra
non monsieur patrick juvet on ne
s'échappe pas aussi facilement au hasard
des rencontres pour l'immortel auteur
d'où sans les femmes interview
impromptue à la volée
est ce que est ce que je proposais de
trois questions sur france 3 michel
bon est ce que vous les voyez les drag
queen recevoir de quoi qu'est ce que
vous en pensez c'est mon travail elle
représente quoi dans le ventre
imaginaire en tant qu'art niveau master
ces nouveaux parce que ça froisse c'est
vraiment pas l'époque d'ici là les
participants je ne sais pas
c'est 95
pourtant ils ont un producteur de
disques au nom dans l'esprit ni dans les
looks
et on avait des trafics ce sabir comme
ça et est ce que vous les trouvez
séduisante
wazemmes maison mesdames ce soir
blache
non leblacher ça va y aller aujourd'hui
contre
alors la fin de tara vasseur
savary josy nouis légal alors ça va de
chennai aux antilles sont incomplets on
sait jamais votre prix moyen d'élèves
voilà c'était très sympa il faut y aller
c'est tous les jeudis reprise qui gagne
j'y serai en venir
aucune boîte parisienne nous voulons
rester à l'avant scène de la nuit ne
peut désormais se priver de leur
présence
pour un patron de discothèque
faire venir des drag queens chez soi
c'est pour une faible rémunération
l'assurance d'une soirée réussie et
d'une case bien pleine
toute une nuit au son de la musique
techno avant qu'au petit matin
apparaissent enfin les taxis du retour
sur la place pigalle
enfin du retour pas tout à fait les
nuits du drag queens sont toujours à
rallonge
ne prennent jamais
il est 6h30 du matin direction donc le
queens vous n'êtes pas couché à moi je
vous le dis
le queens parce qu'elles ne veulent pas
que la nuit sachez que la musique les
abandonne comme si le sommeil devait
sans cesse de reculer
ouais
c'est qu'évidemment
ma
le queens c'est leur domaine leur antre
ne venez pas avant six heures du matin
cela fait ringard paraît-il
descente aux enfers bien accompagné
bienvenue au domaine du queens m
là
il ya des accords
et
ah ouais
alors que pour dario et tyra les rythmes
techno du queens continue de frapper
lola elle est déjà réveillé et au
travail lola est styliste une styliste
de talent qui prépare les costumes de
scène pour le chanteur lenny kravitz
lola elle n'attend pas les petites
enveloppes des patrons de discothèques
pour vivre
[Musique]
toi tu n'as pas tu ne fais pas partie de
ces drag queen qui n'ont que les bars et
la nuit pour gagner un peu d'argent vous
en animation non et puis je pense que
c'est une chance surtout parce que je
pense que c'est un petit peu le miroir
aux alouettes dans la mesure où
effectivement on s'intéresse aux dracs
une en ce moment mais ça va pas durer
non pas de butin mais ternat mais c'est
vrai qu'après ça bon en plus ça elle
prolifère donc c'est le décanat de plus
en plus ça veut dire que je sais pas
s'il ya vraiment un métier d'avenir dans
les règles oui à part peut-être les
chanceuses qui vont faire un guide ou un
film pour toi en tout cas ça doit faire
d'être un métier considéré non non pas
du tout au contraire j'aime bien garder
ce côté ludique parce que ça me permet
de faire ce que je veux en fait j'ai pas
de contraintes vous invite sur un podium
de keller at-elle en journée marge
contre bonds mesdemoiselles
élise mesdemoiselles bonjour je
m'appelle eliane pink harrington et je
vais vous apprendre à marcher allez on y
va mais moiselle avouent elles sont où
rêvent d'être mannequin la bouche plus
décontractée elles sont dans cette école
pour apprendre à défiler avec féminité
le maximum de féminité et c'est un homme
qui leur apprend élire
je pense que c'est pas la peine vraiment
que tu effaces comme ça continue c'est
lui il vient les guider pas à pas vers
les podiums des christian lacroix ou
yves saint laurent de demain
c'est pas mal ce qui fait un peu comme
ça quand ils marchent et vas-y
recommande
la tête droite droite la tête cette
école a choisi donc une drag queen pour
apprendre à des femmes à être plus femme
oui c'est vrai
c'est vraiment
une très sensuelle et il a une façon de
s'habiller
archi il est
il est temps il est adorable et tout ce
qui en fait
tout ce qu'une femme puisqu'elle est un
parfait coup des voix c'est un élève
peut être que les fans sont des jeunes
elles sont parfaites
elles sont chics
elles sont de tous les vernissages à la
mode les ce vernissage est justement à
la pointe de la pointe de la mode
eric rap aux vins tous ses tableaux en
s'inspirant de la même star qu'il
décline sous toutes les couleurs non ce
monsieur n'est pas eric rapeau n'est pas
non plus la star la star la voici c'est
bien sûr lola
[Musique]
lola inspire depuis bientôt trois ans ce
peintre désormais cotées dans le milieu
artistique parisien
pour l'amuser l'artiste le vernissage
est plus que réussi
vous avez déjà eu envie de donner dix
ans de fouilles
c'est très malhonnête
pour pourra troubler les équipes
pascoe
plus une question ici
balle au pied
c'est quand même
courage pour séduire
pour dario et tyra fin de la dernière
séance technique le jour élevé depuis
longtemps
c'est là le seul moment où vous risquez
de vous retrouver face à face avec ses
étranges oiseaux de nuit ces échassiers
et leurs 40 cm de talloires
j'ai gagné au domaine des drag queens
10 heures du matin c'est enfin le temps
du retour à la maison le temps du
silence après 15 heures de bruit
c'est aussi le temps du soulagement pour
les pieds de payera et le temps pour
dario de retrouver ses soeurs les drag
queen
et havrais famille je veux dire ta
famille biologique et on peut regretter
un extraordinaire c'était extraordinaire
je présente mes amis faisant du
d'ailleurs tyra et est venu chez moi
j'essaie présenter avait pas rendre à
cuba drag queen ma mère est venue au
queen m'accompagner au queen images
filmées est venu au bénin café mes
parents sont adorables il compatit
complètement parce que pour eux de moi
au moins je suis heureux eux sont
heureux on fait pas des enfants pour
qu'ils soient à l'image de l'un des
parents si on ne revient que quand on
fait des enfants qu'ils soient c'est pas
journaliste ou avocat ben non enfin
était qu'ils aient
chacun sa personnalité il est comme il
est du mouvement au lui est heureux
j'estime que les parents sont heureux
point bas et cucchi rien du
tout nous avait bien salon tout ça
bah oui bon match la chance que les
miens salah bouda corps qui a été
souillé soir
mondial dames des masques façon je suis
belle bien on ne me retrouve à faire
[Rires]
voilà la vie des drag queens
ça vous plaise ou non c'est comme ça
c'est la vie
pour les gens qui aiment tomber pour eux
pour ceux qui n'aiment pas tant pis
[Musique]